You can almost see the particles floating down here
I have a feeling that the air quality is totally fine fully within acceptable levels
You cannot sit here and tell me that the air quality in this room is the same or worse as out there
especially on the street
You guys ready?
Hey, what's up look who it is I'm back.
The baby daddy are you doing how's life in the studio? Everything's still standing, right? Yeah
How's your baby enjoying college college is great well just think about grad school but she had to pay for yourselves so you know, where's
Sam and Jake probably the back doors closed so I figured yeah
They don't really come out here much the air in the back room is like the best air in the city now
Well i know  there's a air conditioner back there
Well its also filtered. Oh and it's filtered. Yeah. Jake is harvesting that fresh air in the back.
Closing the door wont even let it seep in. Dude hes got a side hustle where he just  jars it and sends it off.
What about Us? In the rabble in the pits?
i thought we were an autonomous collective. You're fooling yourself why living in a dictatorship
so they're just leaving you guys aren't here to fend for yourselves.
Eh  It's fine
Sup dudes.
Whats up.
Come back from having a baby.
WOOO!
Back to the mines.  The content mines.
So you guys just spend all your time back here now?
Oh, yeah
So i got the filter and air conditioner installed
77 degrees the most optimal temperature for thinking.
but it's also got a built-in air filter. And the aroma in here is is perfectly neutral.
We put the air back in sanctuary, you know, The airs fine out there
I mean don't you guys think it might be a little more efficient if you guys out in the front with rest of the team?
Neeko look man. We've been down here making videos for ten years if you guys are new to this channel, by the way
We've been doing this for a little bit and there's some great videos on these channels
My point is we've been down here for 10 years
Sucking in that street juice air out there and it cannot be good for you
You cannot sit here and tell me that the air quality in this room is the same or worse as out there
Especially on the street playing hacky sack. They're just pretending to play hacky sack are they dancing?
I mean Sam you used to live down here? Yeah, and I moved
Yeah, I don't think it's worth risking our health. You're not risking your heath to be out there
It's like smoking you have that one cigarette every day about after two weeks. You're fine
But after ten years, I'm sure the air quality in this room is prized
Actually, I would bet you two air quality in this room is worse than air quality in the front
This is no ventilation in here. No, there's no there's just no way that that's true. We have an airfield there go
how much are you willing to bet. if I can show you guys the air quality in the front of the studio?
It's totally like on par with like health standards. Will you not hold yourselves up back here in this nice little cave.
I mean, it's like betting on the bangles to win the Super Bowl this year. It's just not gonna happen
Ehh i dont watch sports haha.
Let me bet you if you're wrong you'll come back into the sanctuary. alright fine!
Just stare out the glass I've been playing at
God they gotta get back to work. Yeah a Christian new bias like a medium quality air tester
Sure. I've never bought one of those before but I think we can find one it alone
How often do you think about the air that you breathe? It's hard. I'd barely even think about breathing. So again,
do you ever think about the air quality Oh
someone the other things to worry about
constantly every day when I went to Illinois how much feces air am I breathing how much diesel seemed in my
Think about the air quality all the time and that's how you I have asthma not me any breathe sucks
It's not something that like bothers me day to day so I don't worry about in that context
But obviously it'd be nice to have better air Los Angeles won the title of the smokiest American city
19 of the last 20 years
That fresh fresh we dare ya
Weed in the air and conditions up here see all the air conditioners on the ground that building all the air conditioners right there
Everywhere that's weed anytime. There's a warehouse with a ton of air conditioners on the top
It's all weed going. See those buildings down there. That's downtown LA 30 years ago
You would've been able to see it through the smog things have gotten ate a lot better than used to be another dumb dumb
I'm not gonna try to argue that car emissions are great and staying next to highways rape
Alright, I'm gonna say it's that inner studio. All the vents are blocked and I have a feeling that the air quality
Is totally fine totally within acceptable levels. I kind of feel like it's all the same
So I saw a tweet from Hank green the other day saying hey
If you feel bad about your life don't because I just bought don't pair of Haley's and I was inspired
I was like, you know what I will too here
I am a dirty old man with Healy's you see this is what happens when Jake doesn't sit out in the main room anymore Oh
Big so we have this air tester here and what this test for is particulate in the air a test for very fine particulate
which can be inhaled into your lungs and cause lung damage and heavier particulate like actual grains of dust and sand basically when you dust
your shelves, that's the
pm10 level particulate PM 2.5 is very very fine dust and that's a little more dangerous for you because it doesn't get caught by your
Body's mucus and hair and all that kind of stuff that exists to filter the air now LA used to be a very smoggy place
And smog was a combination of like sulfur dioxide carbon dioxide carbon. Monoxide
but as well as
Smoke and smoke is particulate from power planes burning coal from car emissions
and that created this thick layer that would sit in the air and there's equipment like smoking like four packs of cigarettes a day and
That was back in the early 90s late 80s
And since then they have heavily regulated smog with cause this is not going to test for chemicals
This is not going to test for ozone sulfur dioxide co2 any of that kind of stuff
It's just gonna test for particulate but generally speaking. I think it's safe to say that if the particulate is really low
Probably not getting too much chemicals with it disclaimer in this video. We're testing for particulate Classics mark, what is good air?
What are the numbers?
PM 2.5. It is acceptable anything below 12 I guess is good
There's no way we're going to wear clothes. Well down here or 55 and up is bad. Well, that's unhealthy
I don't think we want healthy for sensitive groups includes like our children in your baby. Anything above 12 is bent
It has to be good and that's it period what do you think has the cleanest air in the world America? Not too bad
We always didn't know
In the middle of this fire that's happening. Pm10 is at
776 in the 2.5 s at 500 which is
Awful awful so it can spike drastically don't see the heavy stuff. Let's take it the Beijing
Oh my gosh, dude, this is why all the stuff you get an Amazon is so cheap
It's because there's no environmental regulations in China. There is no way
Twelve or less I would expect it to be somewhere around 100
I think it's that 40 or 50 but who knows, you know air quality can change very rapidly depending on where you are
Well, the guys are obviously out testing the air today
I thought we'd go ahead and test the flavors of today's sponsor hell of fresh because that's how it works
So today we are making some pork tacos pork carnitas pops
I've actually been a subscriber to hella fresh for almost a year now and this is the first time we've sponsored before they do several
Things that really help streamline the cooking process obviously for one. They deliver all the ingredients to you in one box. That's really convenient
I don't like shopping for groceries. I don't know but I can't afford it. Secondly. I like the variety every week
There are new meals and you get to choose whatever meals you want like there's burgers every week tacos every week
There's like pastas every week or vegetarian options, too
If you want you're making a meal using fresh ingredients that they gave you like these are actual
Tomatoes that Christians literally just sliced up and onions and blah no pepper a lime limes
Oh
And on top of that this flex bullying off if you decide to not have meals next week and you just like put a pause
On it like I went on vacation for a couple weeks
I just put a pause in like the meals that I had for like two straight weeks
I was able to resume it again when I got back probably the thing that has helped me most from hellofresh is I
Didn't know how to cook my wife loves cooking
And so she always makes our meals at home because she enjoys it she transferred from the night shift to day shift as a nurse
And now suddenly she's working all day. So I got to make meals I learned how to cook
From I'm not even kidding. I learned how to cook from hellofresh because they have like these instructions
They're super simple to follow now that I've been doing this for like so many months
I actually feel fairly confident with like my cooking skills in general like I can whip stuff up
I'm I'm even altering ingredients. Sometimes just based off of my own experience
I am curious whether or not the particulates that are being cooked and thrown up into the air will even register here like
So many flavors. There's the numbers going down Oh,
Bite that over 100 look at that
180 Flair's is that a lot of flavor? We'll ask yourself
This flavor is 90% smell aka aromas. So most of what you taste is what's already in the air?
It's about to break a thousand
I'm not putting it in me you basically our
prices for hella fresh start just now at
566 per serving get started today with eight free meals and that's $80 off your first month of hellofresh
Go to hello, fresh comm and enter the promo code corridor crew 80 well evidently
This is testing way too many flavors for us to really see if this is good or not. We have to use our mouths
Bon Appetite
Oh
Got that bite got that Chipotle bite
Mmm, let's gonna see if Jake and Sam have feelings or facts it went on in their hearts
So we're gonna go under the highway. We're gonna go closest to the highway possible and we're gonna measure the air quality there
this is basically where we feeling the portal trick shots where aim bot was filmed but you show the million things like here under the
Street that question is did we film ourselves slowly getting cancer there? Let's go find out you can almost see the particles floating down here
Yeah, look we go the highway just
I'm gonna say 99 100 130
I
Don't get it. I mean the air is definitely cleaner than it has been in weeks right now
I can like literally smell like exhaust and themes and stuff here fumes is not the same as a reading here particulate necessarily
Let's go over by the edge of under Street
That was a little higher now
Actually, I'm hitting getting good readings of five five point six
Unbreathable here right now
Look this is points. It's more of a like my throat is burning right now from breathing out here
two point three
If you don't need to be a scientist to stand on the street corner and and know that the air quality is bad
So I'm just a little I'm a little confused. I don't believe any of this. Here's a cigarette
You mind exhaling smoke into this air detector we want to see if it's actually working
Yes, it just jumped up to
157 it works. It works 500 rpm tens or 600 we can say smoking is bad for you
Air purifier Jake listen, should we just go test the back room? Should we just finish this?
We're gonna go on the roof of the studio next to see if the air quality up there is any different except with us on?
The level of the highway normally you can't see those mountains
That's the that's the difference between right now and it's always clear in the fall like this
Well, you know the weather in the studio doesn't really change. All right, here we go science
bringing in the Sun we got oh
my god
1.5
Moving the air quality in our studio is worse than outside. Does that mean?
Something here. It's pretty good chance. It's gonna be worse inside. But now that I start thinking about this critically
Alright, let's test the air collide in this studio. I
See this no one contaminate the air everyone hold it in
Three
three
It's worse than here that it is outside right now saying three doesn't mean anything
Per meter squared
2.54 micrometers since now let's see. What kind of ppm is in deep snow. Eh, dude
Sixty-six
Test is the safe air sanctuaries everything it's cracked up to be
Here we go
3i
It's like you're telling me that like blue is the red and red is green
Like I'm just like but I was there under the freeway and it smelled like subscribe
Maybe it's all those things that aren't particulate but I don't think it's as bad for you as particles the air quality in LA
It's rare days like this where you can actually see downtown
Clearly if you came back and you measured this on a smoggy day
You'd see readings at least 10 times as high as we're seeing today when we look at the official readings for the area
it's a lot higher PM 2.5 for this area is
technically in a
22.5 according to the state's equipment who knows why it's different from what we're reading. That's what it says
And it says generally la is kind of in that same area. I think the big takeaway here is
You all got to get on the back room and hang out on the floor all your boys
Because we're all here creating the same era together Nikko you feel like you've proved it to me
Like I should move out into the main area here
But I think we need to strongly consider a little bit more data before anyone makes any
Serious decisions like moving away from the sanctuary. Their quality is subjective and you should just let us live our lives in. Peace
It wasn't as bad in LA as I thought for particulate or didn't measure chemicals
I definitely know it's something but at the same time it's like particulate so low and here I can't imagine there's any like higher
Concentration of chemicals I will say however that looking at the rest of the world really open my eyes and how bad things can get
And that we are very lucky that we have the economic resources and the regulations out here to keep the air
Somewhat clean because back thirty years ago. It was really bad in LA. It's just like Beijing
So hopefully in time Beijing and there is over in China or India or anywhere else that has crappy air
Hopefully in time that can improve so as jake pointed out
It's actually a very nice day outside the fact that rain this weekend
Which actually takes all the particulate out of the air in LA?
It takes time for the cars and everything to kick that back up
So we're going to continue taking readings and if you want to see we're all slowly getting lung cancer
Follow us on instagram at corridor digital neil post readings every once in a while
There's also a link in the description below for your convenience. Thanks for watching. Don't forget to subscribe. It's hovering at 11:00 now
It's skyrocketing at our 3d printers matters the dust
4472 ET I don't want to be in here anymore. It stopped at 87th and the pm10 is about to burqa hundred
Have fun with your peepee